thank you
whatever
it takes
that phrase
and those press conferences
were my introduction to so many of you
as chancellor
it was daunting to face such a challenge
in my first days in office
and what it also meant
is that more than a year has gone by
before i'd have the chance to meet you
all properly
and that's why these last few days have
been such a joy
meeting you all face to face
and hearing so many of you say to me
wow
you're even shorter in real life
nothing can ever prepare you to become
chancellor especially in recent times
there have been occasions when it really
did feel like the world was collapsing
in those moments
there are certain things i fell back on
yes my family
yes my colleagues
yes my tremendous treasury team
and yes
the person who made all this possible
the person who delivered a thumping
conservative majority my friend our
leader the country's prime minister
boris johnson
but the other thing
i fell back on
is something we all have in this room
our values
our conservative
values i believe in some straightforward
things
i believe that mindless ideology is
dangerous i'm a pragmatist i care about
what works not about the purity of any
dogma
i believe
in fiscal responsibility
just borrowing more money and stacking
up bills for future generations to pay
is not just economically irresponsible
it is immoral
because
because
because
it's this no it's not the state's money
it's your money
i believe
that the only sustainable route out of
poverty comes from having a good job
it's not just the pounds it puts in your
pockets
it's the sense of worth and
self-confidence it gives you
so i will do whatever i can to protect
people's livelihoods and create new
opportunities too
and when it comes to those new
opportunities i am very much a child of
my time
i spent the formative years of my career
working around technology companies in
california
and i believe the world is at the
beginning of a new age of technological
progress which can bring jobs
wealth and transformed lives
so
pragmatism
fiscal responsibility
a belief in work and an unshakable
optimism about the future
this is who i am this is what i stand
for this is what it will take and we
will do whatever it takes
and there can be
no prosperous future
unless it is built on the foundation of
strong public finances
i have to be blunt with you our recovery
comes with a cost
our national debt is almost a hundred
percent of gdp
so we need to fix our public finances
because strong public finances don't
happen by accident they are a deliberate
choice they are a legacy for future
generations and a safeguard against
future threats
i'm grateful
we should all be grateful to my
predecessors and their 10 years of sound
conservative management of our economy
they
they believed in fiscal responsibility
i believe in fiscal responsibility and
everyone in this hall does too
and whilst i know
tax rises are unpopular
some will even say
unconservative i'll tell you what is
unconservative
unfunded pledges
reckless borrowing and soaring debt
anyone who tells you that you can borrow
more today
and tomorrow will simply sort itself out
just doesn't care about the future
so yes i want tax cuts but in order to
do that our public finances must be put
back on a sustainable footing
now labour's track record on the public
finances speaks for itself
since 2010 we've had five labour leaders
seven shadow chancellors and innumerable
spending pledges and in all that time
they still haven't got the message
the british people won't trust a party
that isn't serious with their money and
that's why they vote conservative
we would we must never forget that the
fundamental economic differences between
us and labor run very deep
differences not just about debt and
borrowing
but about how to deal
with the real pressures people face in
their lives
and right now
we are facing challenges to supply
chains not just here but right around
the world and we are determined to
tackle them head on
but tackling the cost of living isn't
just a political sound bite
it's one of the central missions of this
conservative government
picture this
you're a young family
you work hard saving a bit each month
but it's tough you have ambitions for
your careers for your children you want
to give them the best more than you had
now you tell me
is the answer to their hopes and dreams
just to increase their benefits is the
answer to tell that young family the
economic system is rigged against you
and the only way you stand a chance is
to lean ever more on the state
be in no doubt
that
is the essence of the labor answer
and not only does labour's approach
not work in practice
it is a desperately sad vision for our
future
but
there is
an alternative
an approach focused on good work
better skills and higher wages approach
that says yes we believe in you we will
help you and you will succeed
and better still it's more than words
it's a plan in action a conservative
plan and conference it is working
[Applause]
governments
rarely get to set the tests by which
they will ultimately be judged
and our test
is jobs
remember as economies around the world
pulled the shutters down
forecasters were predicting unemployment
to reach 12
millions of people were on the precipice
of losing their jobs their livelihoods
their homes
well
the forecasts were wrong
the unemployment rate is at less than
five percent and falling that's lower
than france america canada italy and
spain
and we now have one of the fastest
recoveries of any major economy in the
world
now
it wasn't that the forecasters had bad
models no
it's just their models did not take
account of one thing
and that was this conservative
government our will to act and our plan
to deliver
an increased national living wage the
restart program sector-based work
academies doubling work coaches
job-finding support traineeships
apprenticeship incentives skills boot
camps and the prime minister's lifetime
skills guarantee
all things we are doing that won't just
help people but will give them the means
and the opportunities to help themselves
i believe in good work and better skills
and higher wages i believe that every
person in this country has the potential
to become something greater and i know
that we and only we the conservative
party are the ones that can make that
happen
and our economy
cannot be what we need it to be without
the courage creativity and sheer force
of will that each new generation brings
yet
at its peak
just under one in three workers under 25
were on furlough
one in three
that's a million people
who didn't have the fallback of a career
history or a network of contacts and in
many cases hadn't even moved into their
first real job
so what did we do
we created the kickstart scheme up
running and working in a matter of
months a landmark program that is
helping young people start exciting new
careers
and thanks to our plan
young people
just like john ceharo introduced me
today
are starting those new jobs in their
thousands
so
to give more young people the same
chances john i can confirm that we are
expanding our successful plan for jobs
into next year
the kickstart scheme extra support
through the youth offer the job entry
targeted support scheme and our
apprenticeship incentives all extended
because we believe in the awesome power
of opportunity and we are going to make
sure that no young person in our country
is left without it
[Applause]
but what we do today
means little
if we don't also have a plan
for tomorrow
a plan
for the future
a future economy shaped by the forces of
science technology and imagination
the years i spent in california left a
lasting mark on me working with some of
the most innovative and exciting people
in finance and technology watching ideas
become reality seeing entrepreneurs
build new teams
it's not just about the money
i saw a culture
a mindset which was unafraid to
challenge itself reward hard work and
was open to all those with a talent to
achieve
i look across the united kingdom
and that culture is here too
in the young people i've already spoken
about today unencumbered by timidity and
orthodoxy
and it's there in our willingness to
take risks
not just on companies but on people
people with the raw potential to create
a wave of the most dynamic high growth
companies a wave that will reach the
farthest corners of the world
that optimism
that unshakeable belief that the future
can be different and better was also at
the heart of brexit
i remember over five years ago
being told that if i backed brexit my
political career would be over before it
had even begun well i put my principles
first and i always will
i was proud to back brexit proud to back
leave and that's because despite the
challenges in the long term i believe
the agility flexibility and freedom
provided by brexit would be more
valuable in a 21st century global
economy than just proximity to a market
that in the long term a renewed culture
of enterprise willingness to take risks
and be imaginative would inspire changes
in the way we do things at home
brexit was never just about the things
we couldn't do
it was also about the things we didn't
do
that's why we've introduced the super
deduction a uk first in tax policy which
is triggering an explosion in capital
investment that's why we created the
help to grow scheme another uk first to
help small and medium-sized companies
digitize skill up and scale up that's
why we launched the future fund another
uk first in government investment
backing high potential startups
my point is this
even if you can't see it yet i assure
you the future
is here
last year alone the uk attracted more
venture capital investment to our
startups than france and germany
combined
and
along with enhanced infrastructure and
improved skills
we are going to make this country
not just a science superpower not just
the best place in the world to do
business i believe we are going to make
the united kingdom the most exciting
place in the planet
take artificial intelligence once the
stuff of science fiction now it's
reality and we are a global leader
the steam engine kicked off the
industrial revolution computers
delivered automation the internet
brought information exchange and as the
latest general purpose technology ai has
the potential to transform whole
economies and societies
if artificial intelligence were to
contribute just the average productivity
increase of those three technologies
that will be worth around 200 billion
pounds a year to our economy and so
today i'm announcing that we will create
2 000 elite ai scholarships for
disadvantaged young people and double
the number of turing ai world leading
research fellows helping to ensure
that the most exciting industries and
opportunities are open to all parts of
our society
new policy focused on innovative
technology supporting jobs for the next
generation a sign of our ambition for
the future
because that's why
we are here
all of us
that's why we became members of the
conservative party
that's why you all give up so much of
your time sacrificing things that are
important to you in order to help build
a better future
you know the longer i spend in this job
the more i realize that the worst parts
of politics are driven
by fear
fear of change
fear of losing the fear of being wrong
even fear of the future
and when people get scared
they create divisions
they say
you're either with us
or you're with them
but you cannot make progress if you're
pitting people against each other
that's what you get from a tired fearful
sort of politics
we saw it last week in brighton
it's not just that labour don't like us
they don't even like each other
where is we
the conservatives
are now and always will be the party of
business
and the party of the worker the party of
the private sector and the public sector
a party up for the old and the young the
british people want a party that can get
things done
so at just the moment when it feels like
we've done enough
that we've gotten through that we can
take a rest we must not stop now is the
time to show them that our plan will
deliver and now is the time at last at
long last to finally turn to the future
thank you
you